good afternoon it's a privilege to
introduce commissioner p vaults this is
our second session of the leaders in
global energy the first lecture was
given by mr. Tanaka and now it's an
honor to have Commissioner p bolts who
was the energy commissioner in the first
bajos Commission and now the development
commission beforehand he was he had the
velo political career in his country
where I tried to tell it by heart
Minister education Member of Parliament
head of the Finance Commission in
Parliament Minister finance and Deputy
Prime Minister I think that I got almost
everything and Commissioner free ball
has made an amazing job as energy
commissioner for five years I had the
privilege when I was ministering my
country to work together with him and I
have no words to express how elmire what
he did and for us it's great to have the
opportunity to hear you enter them to to
divide energy policy in
well thank you ma are a kind fellow I
will try to later on answer all your
questions I tried in my speech very much
to make a relation between my current
job because I'm now be You Commissioner
for developments it means that they've
to be more precise development
cooperation so it means that everything
relates to EU relations with developing
countries in Africa Asia or Latin
America it's my job and invite have
experience of the Energy Commission for
five years so if I try to make up well
try to dress both sides of faith in
connection but that means that I will
not be in my speech expert not on each
of these parts all your very much
welcome to ask any detailed question if
you would like and I will try to answer
as well as good as I can well ladies and
gentlemen we all take energy for granted
giving lit so to the complexity in
fragility of the systems that brings it
to us it is it's a heart of our way of
life reflect on why at the most basic
level great civilizations have fallen
and vorse have been won and lost and you
will find that in a lot of cases that
the reason his energy insufficient
slaves in grain to means the expectation
of a Roman citizen deforestation for the
Mayans are just two examples in my new
responsibilities as European Development
Commissioner within nao a budget of
almost 7 billion euros to help to lift
or unser the first population out of
poverty I have become all too aware of
the importance of the energy to us
collectively and individually in the
dangers of complacency in both human
development and environment
environmental terms but before talking
about energy development and powered
elevation I would like to discuss
enormous chances that have taken changes
that have taken place in use energy
policies over the last five years these
changes have said they you on a course
that all developed countries will need
to follow sooner rather than later and
these changes are breathtaking they mark
the beginning of the change from the
full fossil fuel-powered European
economy to a truly sustainable one but
practically all they use energy needs
will be met by co2 natural energy
sources by 2050 a change that has to be
made over Lippman's in a single
generation when one considers that today
fossil fuels provide about eighty
percent of the use overall energy needs
and around fifty percent of its
electricity the description of energy
revolution is for once truly justified
prior to 2000 they you did not in any
real sense have a common energy policy
but the series of gently coordinated
national ones however at the same time
three issues led to real concentration
of attention on energy firstly all
prices increase rapidly from what had
been considered for some years as
something of a normal energy price
around thirty dollars borrow mark two
seventy dollars plus secondly at the
borders of the you at this view was
brewing between Russia and the Ukraine
over the use of transit pipelines
applying almost a quarter of the use gas
supply this raises specter of shortages
and cut power cuts in Ju and indeed in
general 2006 Russia cut off supplies to
the Ukraine if only for a limited time
before a solution was reached
wordly the European Union collectively
understood the significance of climate
change it recognized a very simple fact
with just over 6 billion people on the
planet today we are living quite
literally unsustainably by this I mean
that if he continued to act as we do now
we're all day today our behavior is
significantly harming the basic physical
cycles that run ours planet ecosystem it
will help profoundly negative effects on
the quality of life for future
generations and now where can this be
more easily seen than the regarding the
carbon cycle this is illustrated by the
graph which indicates co2 levels since a
year to 7,000 measured from polar icecap
samples note what happens following the
invention of the combustion engine by
James Watt in 1765 so the european
union's position on climate change is
very clear and i would like to
characterize it as follows the european
union accepts that human behavior is
responsible for increased co2
atmospheric levels these levels are
causing the earth to slowly heat up if
left unchallenged on the basis of best
available science Joaquin can expect
that planet to warm by four degrees
centigrade or more by the end of present
century also mapping precisely the
effect of such temperature increases
beyond human experience we can
confidently predict that aside from
rising sea levels melting ice caps and
biodiversity reduction due to vastly
changed rainfall patterns it will lead
to unprecedented coming and migration
and this cannot be allowed to happen so
they you also accept the
the developed world is responsible for
pretty much of Osseo to present Lynn's
atmosphere and that was developing
countries how to play sash fair share
the developed world will how to make the
greatest cuts themselves it is on the
basis of these three challenges that
they you developed its new energy policy
generally referred to as a 20 20 20
energy policy put simply say you has
decided the following irrespective of
action elsewhere it will take the
necessary action to reduce its
greenhouse gas emissions by twenty
percent by 2020 even when a convincing
international agreement is reach it will
increase this reduction by thirty
percent by 2020 this much much greater
cut by 2050 and this is very fundamental
point when I have thought about changing
energy policy well it's very much you
need to point of departure and basically
you can measure of imports of energy
resources but you can measure impact on
energy also through co2 emissions so the
point of co2 missions being put adds a
centerpiece of energy policy
intellectual is correct it's not only
because in vantos because it's very
clear correlation with energy sector
well in order to do this Scott say you
has adopted an emission trading system
whereby almost no co2 producing industry
will have to reduce emissions by an
average of twenty one percent by 2020
compared to two thousand five levels in
addition the U has agreed clear targets
to improve energy efficiency by twenty
percent by 2020 meaning that we can
expect to reduce our overall energy use
by fourteen percent compared to so 2005
in this area we went to two
van is regulatory framework and another
one is well incentives because energy
efficiency we still try to find the best
market mechanism so that's why well
regulatory framework was quite important
one was well decisions that was
unprecedented is it is phasing out that
incandescent light bulbs just on basis
of their energy performance I would say
it is rather dangerous in a way step but
if you really need to come to energy
efficiency you need to come with a
Samara that draws very strongly public
attention and I believe that society is
a call accepted this step because it's
very difficult to bend the product just
on the basis on an energy performance on
climate change performance so that says
I think some things that need to really
to be well very much taken into account
and another step was also unprecedented
in EU history EU has agreed legally
binding targets according to which
member states will increase the level of
renewable energies they use so that by
2020 the European Union as a whole the
source twenty percent of its energy
needs from renewable energy sources
compared to around eight point five
percent today why it is unprecedented
step because we never ever had legally
binding target concept in the youth 27
state so it basically means that if the
country doesn't reach its target it will
be going in front of court of justice
and it could face a fine so that
basically is a huge incentive to country
to really to achieve this target is it
the best method well it's very much
related to sovereignity because it's
very clear that to really to go in this
area you could go all across the you
with some measures corazon what to use
driving forces in each and every country
so we will see how it will work out but
this definitely gives a lot of
flexibility and chance for the partners
like Manuel who really could mastermind
if you have something very strong
backing behind you and where the country
have subscribed and something very
substantial and they I would mention
that part of the strategy is very much
related also to strength and energy
competition inside EU market not just
national market but the you markets
which trying to promote more
interconnexion separation from
production and transmission grid and
trying to really to promote power
exchanges that is very much trying to
reunite them involve well but 2020
target definitely huge challenges we
believe that there is no other choice so
that means that if we do not take this
action today then by 2020 we will not be
in position to achieve the cuts up to
eighty percent that is generally
accepted that will be required us to
secure a global climate change agreement
we refuse to believe that such a global
agreement is not possible because we
believe that this would be responsible
and the willingness on EU salt is to do
anything for the name of the securing
our children's future and that I think
is really important to follow it so the
you has made this commitment and the
changes are happening on the ground we
have already used emission levels by
seventeen percent since 1990 in 2009 we
installed a record level of renewable
electricity capacity and launched a
major new clean electricity new clean
energy research program we have adopted
a new emission trading directive because
that is also force that drives
this energy consumption and efficient
user of strategy across the broad board
phasing out free allowances at the first
stage we gave three allowances and I
think our experience definitely
demonstrates that you need to auction
them and this auctioning is now norm not
exception so I have no doubt that we
will achieve this target and there's
interesting scene by 2020 we will be
wondering why we were so timid want the
benefits in terms of jobs growth more
predictability in energy prices and
technology exports become increasingly
evident I would like to finish this tour
of some of our elements of EU energy
policy by reflecting on longer-term
challenges in doing solves a need for
immediate ambition of all developing
countries become evident as I mentioned
it is commonly accepted that in order to
secure an effective international
agreement on climate change developed
countries will how to accept a cut in
emissions levels of as much as eighty
percent if not more given expected
growth of emissions in developing world
these emission cuts will how to be
achieved in developed world so cutting
emissions by eighty percent in you will
require quite simply a very close to
zero carbon electricity system road
transport system and heating and cooling
sectors for the building's the remaining
twenty percent co2 emissions will be
needed for RS varied actions are far
from simple such as agriculture marathon
and air transport so such a societal
change is possible but it will really
require massive commitment and
definitely every day counts so you use
2020 and
20 20 20 energy policy has not
implicated its determination to tackle
climate change and to achieve energy
security it has it acted and will
continue to do so now I would like to
talk with a link about this development
policy and the energy challenges that
are inherent to its success just a
couple of weeks ago the United Nations
reviewed progress in achieving the
millennium development goals established
in 2000 these goals represent a major
achievement and much has been done eight
levels have increased level of
governance in many developing countries
has greatly improved a number of goals
such as the aim of lifting fifty percent
of people out of extreme poverty can
confidently be expected to be met
however progress is far for even on mdgs
and most importantly achievements differ
enormously geographically with roughly
speaking most progress being made in
Asia less in Africa and some countries
even losing ground achieving these goals
is not an option and I am convinced that
it should be possible the European Union
will certainly play more than its fair
roll it presently grants about sixty
percent of all global development a and
the European Union recently reaffirmed
determination to increase this level
from zero point forty six percent of the
you gross national income today to 0.7
percent in 2050 there are many elements
to achieving the mdgs from the need for
all developed countries to set step up
eight levels to the need for developing
countries to refocus efforts on
governance
to ensure that all Aid is well span in
particular I am determined to ensure
that through a combination of policies
all Europeans union said is focused as a
high impact a8 that results in benefits
to citizens for generations to come that
act as a catalyst for growth and
development aid alone will never achieve
the MDGs let alone the real aim of
global power to elevation only when we
use it as an engine for growth we will
achieve our aims and this is where
energy and in particular electricity can
play a center stage without a reliable
predictable energy source growth can
never flourish without electricity how
can we hope to bring clean water to
every citizen how can we hope for good
education without electricity when
internet teaching has to become a key
support to schools how can universal
based universal basic health care be
achieved so electricity is a key
precondition to practically all the MDGs
and yet today so much of the world's
poorest citizens have no access to
alleble reliable supply of electricity
the latest data is I think 1.4 billion
people that doesn't have the world
energy council estimated in 2005 that
less than half of urban population of
sub-saharan Africa has access to
electricity and only 74 in five percent
of rural citizens and those with
supplies are subject to endless power
cuts this is a huge driver of poverty
without access to electricity how can we
pretend that people have a chance to
pull
sells out of poverty an elective
vacation presents not just huge
challenges in terms of poverty but
definitely also of climate change
according to a study by the French
population and development center the
population of sub-saharan Africa
decimated by the slave trade in
colonization stood at 100 million in
1990 it has grown more than Sevenfold to
770 million by 2005 and by 2050 it will
grow by as much as 2.6 x about that
level 22 billion so the picture for
Africa as a call is similar as it is
much more of the developing world indeed
the United Nations expects global
population to increase by almost fifty
percent of today's levels by 2050 again
much of the growth coming from the
developing world with economic growth
rates constantly and thankfully
exceeding five percent in many African
countries the potential growth in
greenhouse gas emissions looks
frightening and unchecked threatens to
render irrelevant any cuts made in zeh
you and the rest of developed world
however the need to address climate
change cannot be a reason to constrain
economic growth in world's poorest
countries this must be a given the you
uses more electricity to power its
fridges that the entire consumption of
750 million citizens in sub-saharan
Africa by way of comparison Ju the
United States uses twice the amount of
electricity per capita than the European
Union and can't 100 times more than any
canyon citizen
as is often the case the challenge can
becomes an opportunity in Copenhagen Z
developed world committed to provide
nearly 30 billion u.s. dollars a fast
start finance for developing countries
during 2010 2012 as well as a goal for
mobilizing jointly van hundred billion
u.s. dollars a year by 2020 providing
the developing countries put in place
meaningful mitigations actions and
transparent about and D transparent
about the greenhouse gas emissions so
the opportunities for sustainable growth
in the developing world and in much in
Africa in particular are huge Africa for
example has enormous untapped renewable
energy resources run ranging from hydro
to solar wind biomass geothermal many
areas are not yet covered by
transmission and distribution
infrastructure the possibilities as
exists in many areas to skip a
technological generation and by using
locally based renewable production
avoids a significant cost that comes
with electricity distribution
infrastructure which in the european
union accounts for up to fifty percent
of final domestic targets this in turn
improves very significantly the
competitiveness of renewable generated
electricity compared to more traditional
forms such as coal or gas based
generation furthermore just as in the
you investing in renewable energy
provide jobs and is an engine for growth
relying on important energy not always
dozes and by investing massively in
renewable energy the developing vote can
escape
the boom-and-bust pattern so often
triggered by oil price volatility in
order to create a real change a
revolution in the way Africa generates
and supplies its energy determined and
coordinated action is needed these are
this it is unlikely that these
sustainable sources will be exploited Oh
at the very least it will happen far too
slowly both in terms of the potential
for development and in terms of avoiding
new fossil-based generation that once
built will emit co2 for generations to
come I believe that together with a use
partner countries in developing world we
need to make huge effort to catalyze
this change the European Union is
uniquely Valley clip to provide this
assistance it is a leading producer of
new renewable energy it causes some of
the major renewable technology companies
and it has the greatest experience in
the legal and administer measures
necessary to catalyze investment in
renewable energy an investment in energy
do not per se need significant ground
related assistance this is important
development funding alone will never be
able to finance the trillions of euros
of investment necessary to provide every
citizen in developing world with
sustainable electricity indeed in
principle such investment can be
profitable in all cases they would
produce a significant income stream even
if in some cases at the beginning that
income stream would be not sufficient to
cover all initial Kappa Kappa capital
and operational costs but so much can be
done in relatively limited funds a
perfect example high
backed aid in order to catalyze an Evan
ergy revolution financing is needed
through development banks and financial
institutions such as European Investment
Bank the World Bank and the African
Development Bank stable regulatory and
administer conditions are needed which
will enable and encourage investment by
private companies this range from grid
issues tax company law to planning rules
it also requires legal provisions
allowing open competition on electricity
markets to supply customers and it
requires technical knowledge education
and training in many parts of developing
world the technical training facilities
for electrical engineers are inadequate
or do not exist without a well-trained
workforce renewable electricity will
never meet its potential and maintenance
will be an increasing problem so job
creation is a center of benefit of any
such development but training and
knowledge will require real efforts it
is surely possible to address all of
these issues with the necessary
political will this is why I am
presently considering how you can commit
to combine parts of its development and
climate change founding bringing
together its various Development Bank's
with other financial institutions and
developing new instruments from long
ground landing to risk sharing
facilities covering political and and
mr. risks in addition using they use
technical expertise and is developing
funding an ambitious engineering
training program which newly established
Institute's might be established in
Africa and elsewhere in developing ball
transferring technology and knowledge
with the close involvement of EU and
African universities grid companies
an electricity companies such measures
therefore form the basis of new energy
partnerships between they you and
developing countries or regional
groupings to progressively provide
sustainable electricity to every citizen
the opportunities are there and we can
achieve them ladies and gentlemen there
are many conclusions that one might they
make from this be brief tour of the US
energy policy and the challenges of
energy in development I would like to
make only one and that is needed to say
imagine imagine that we have the courage
to decide that we truly will will truly
address the climate change that we will
accept our most basic responsibility
towards future generation that we are
willing to pay some twenty percent more
for our energy to ensure that by 2050 it
is sustainable imagine how many
high-quality jobs would be created
across the globe extent of exporting
wells also imagine how much more
pleasant our streets and air would be
when all cars are electric imagine that
every citizen irrespective of where he
or she's board has access to sustainable
electricity giving all a chance to grow
and when you really think about it it's
not hard to imagine also so that means
that we really can transform the energy
vote thank you very much for your
attention
thank you very much and this for your
brilliant lecture I would like to ask us
to raise some class ha could you start
you invite us in the end to imagine and
one year ago it was a little easier to
imagine because there was Copenhagen
coming where all these objectives you
you have presented seemed to be shared
by a very large group of countries and
to resonate a lot with a public opinion
after the disappointing Copenhagen GOP
how do you see Europe continuing to push
forward with these policies in a global
climate which has mean global political
climate which has become much more
skeptical and where countries like China
in particular and very mixed signals of
turning the development of green
technologies into industrial policy
competition and and providing a less
encouraging environment for EU policies
is that it is not there a risk for the
EU to be taken advantage of and how to
try to deal with that well basically
answer unfortunately is my current job
because if you go to African countries
and you speak with people basically they
recognize that there are evident changes
of climate change access to water has
decreased so they have seen the real
pattern so as a result the investment in
agriculture is less productive so the
chances for purnima is much more
stronger so basically the driver what
will be from the most porous can't
propose people because we will not be
able to deal with supplying development
aid so all we really start to address
this you or not because EU i would say
its secondary in this respect you could
help visa system
that we have put in place because Co do
has a price so basically means that the
U has put a burden on classical energy
industry so it's in evidence it's
evidence but as a result you see that
there are substantial changes well new
investment in wind parks inshore and
offshore even is going on so you see
that the solar valleys being more used
than solar is used also in concentrated
solar power but most of all what you
would see the biggest driver is energy
efficiency what happens now when i was
first time appointed and has talked
about energy efficiency people saw the
time just a joke so to be honest that
well it's not the point now it's
mainstream policy in each and every
country the firm eschewed refurbishing
buildings seeing as a transport that is
more efficient it's a part of the know
so i would say the drive will come from
the most poorest countries because they
are most exposed to the climate change
and they would expect actually than 20
billion sour delivered and handled
billions of delivered that was promised
by the way so that we say oh they are in
this game and if the money will not come
they will be very very upset and angry
and they really have will be right to do
and you visit systems in place would
demonstrate that nothing happens very
bad if you put some burden on energy for
transformation and my experience is that
well basically every opposition to
renewable energy and energy efficiency
both said you increase the cost it's not
competitive and the experience we get we
have not used always the most efficient
system to be honest and still the
transformation goes and we are still
competitive and still alive so they
basically mean that you can't put some
additional burden on the sector that you
would like to have a transformation so
if i believe these two trends will meet
together and by the way also a lot of
developing countries are very much
convinced that it should be done they
understand that is able
be locked in but well we need a critical
mass cancun will be one step further but
I think it's inevitable that we don't
manage to have this agreement it will be
longer you are right the public opinion
is down now but it was also partially
that evo the board changed now it's a
new well i would say climate change so
there have been a lot of changes and I
believes it have been very high
expectations that in Copenhagen we will
achieve more I think that was people
expected but well they should not be
discouraged two years lost three years
lost well okay it's not the biggest
tragedy in life I am quite convinced
there is no way how countries will move
out of it and they will agree it's
basically who should play paid the price
but if you discover that the price is
helper for energy security and also for
employment then you start to think a bit
differently about it so I hope that this
Drive will be strong and sustainable
hello and thank you for your talk I have
a question about the EU role in
promoting energy access and sustainable
development you talked about the
potential in Africa and elsewhere for
infrastructure to skip a generation to
move into renewable energy and you also
spoke about the potential role of the
European Investment Bank the World Bank
very large international institutions
how do these very large institutions get
the money to local sources to make
smaller investments in renewable energy
to promote both sustainable development
and economic growth coming from the
bottom up so how is the money structured
and what would that look like
well we hover we deftly spend I think on
Africa energy over Moses sources
investment bank and and also envelopes
coming from me you were roughly two
billion i think yearly but the needs are
huge and they use at this stage only
grant system so that what my intention
is really to get long ground blending
and to how facilities that would respond
those projects produced by developing
countries themselves or energy programs
or are just individuals that would like
to have so the point is at this stage is
scale that we have well amount of
financial resources and that's why I
think that developing countries do not
have this so the reason is to get
financial institutions in place to do
this and to do this process cheaply
enough so i am trying to increase the
scale delivery system is not very much
different you can have say its climate
change instruments of World Bank's there
is national country program so I don't
afraid of this I am afraid that the
scale is not there and and we can't
expect sufficient grounds so that means
long ground blending is the only
possibility that could be used thank you
for giving us a speech sir you cannot
mention the issue of 2009 Russia and
Ukraine gas crisis at the beginning of
your speech but could you please
elaborate more on how does that
particular event our impact on youth
energy security policy because you rely
heavily on the import of oil and gas so
I wonder if that's going to cause a
shift in the I used energy trade with
other countries in the world thank you
well youyou is huge importer of energy
and for a long time it was been expected
that we are so attractive
market that nobody would sink ever to
cut supplies well development has
provided many customers for energy
resources and that's why we discovered
that we we are good perhaps customer but
we are not the only customer in the
world what happened between Russian
Ukraine was was ballot or dispute it was
nothing to do with us but it definitely
for neither one or four of the other V
as a customer's play that enroll so to
be honest well there have been some
measures that they try to bridge but
still basically they have been so
involved in say bilateral conflicts at
val small suffering from customer side
it was not so important but for us it
meant a lot because it's very clearly
you need to diversify you don't need
diversify supply of energy resources
recently I met for example the
deliveries a Turkish Minister of Foreign
Affairs and he said that Nabucco that a
lot of people has said will never fly is
moving reasonably well it's still not on
the critical stage but it's going well
and by Nabucco is important it doesn't
change too much towards the volumes of
gas that we got from Russia but it is
another independent supplier we are have
agreed on North steam pipe lines it was
very much disputed and it gives the same
supplier Russia but it's didn't even a
different supply route so we getting
more energy security definitely they are
so we increased interconnections inside
EU because when you have an input in
Spain in LNG it should be ability to
transport its own words and Norwegian
gas good or Russian gas could come
selves basically where we have had the
problems it will be related to the
competition issues because companies
don't like another supplier on the
market they need compete and that's why
it's where you try to promote
competition but also you stimulate
investment so the lesson from Ukraine
Russia crisis was more i would say there
will be no suffering but it's learned
you need to diversify and that also
reason why we promote so much also
renewable energy because renewable
energy is another security element of
supply and and most of the important
security of supply element is energy
efficient try consume less if you
consume less you will be more
independent they may your energy
security so it was not it was just what
wake-up call I would say it's not some
things that was deliberately done by any
of the countries but just exposed you
can't rely on van supply route from one
supplier even if you have the big was
the biggest trust in this supply
supplier in the world all right thanks
for taking my question now I'm looking
at the picture of the little African
girl and I'm thinking about what her
opportunity is and what her choices are
and you know unfortunately her market
for choices is really driven by a lot of
multinationals that perhaps are
supplying the light bulb that you
mentioned and you know private
institutions are they're going to profit
maximize and you can create incentives
within the ue you like carbon caps you
mentioned to limit their profit
maximization schemes but how do you
create policy incentives so they
continue to limit that in developing
countries because currently they're not
well I think it's right if you take
rural areas that's definitely we need to
work as a classical development aid
project because for rural areas I have
seen my have a couple of solar panels
change while water supply in the village
who gives more opportunities servicing
energy should be one of the mainstream
policies in classical development
cooperation what concerns the city's
well regulatory framework is needed
let's take example of Nigeria I would
say that the country has a huge
potential
and very difficult electricity supply
and it's not that people wouldn't like
to invest you need the right framework
in Lagos because most of the people use
very expensive like this degeneration
they have a vowels they use a out
generator and based on fuel oil so
basically if there would be very clever
policy market to drive it so there would
be no need really to come these huge
investments back up some investments in
needed so decentralized investment
should be mainstream policy in rural
areas because that's I agree there is no
market signals at this stage but if I
would compare combined it these a food
security in agriculture policy that
could work because with the time it
could evolve so I would say we should
all the things that at the end of the
day for the service delivered you need
to pay and I think that is shouldn't be
lost from visit because if it's free of
charge it's it's not long-term issue
because at the end of the maintenance
should be paid new investment with it so
some symbolic charges well later on
who'd been wrong in introduced but for
today I am saying let's concentrate on
energy in developing world thanks for
your very interesting presentation in
the US energy reform recently has become
really part of a larger effort to reform
the financial markets and the dodd-frank
act includes several measures that could
vary significantly transform the wave
energy comma and other commodities are
traded in dec just recently we've seen a
similar effort to reform commodities and
energy markets in Europe this has been a
focus in recent weeks and it has been
announced as a very high priority of
friends when it assumes the presidency
of the EC next month do you see those
two efforts going hand-in-hand you see
much how many much homogenized nation
between those two regulatory reform
or do you see a potential for some
divergence and perhaps some regulatory
arbitrage between us and ec markets and
how do you think this will affect
developing countries do you think
African countries for instance my
benefit by having more predictable
energy prices and energy markets and
what do you think might be the potential
for African countries and other
developing countries to tap emissions
markets including emission futures
market to finance their effort to
develop their energy infrastructure well
i will start backups with some site
questions and don't try to mow toe to a
very complex question you said well what
France tried to go well it is so I would
say good luck for French president's
they try to address very fundamental
issue how's the price price formation on
commodities market because a lot of this
have been created after the Second World
War and it's not very much corresponding
to the real issue real situation so if
subtrans would like to have more fair
and more well responsive to kind
environment the commodities trading
rules and the risk is that most
brilliant intellectual scheme could not
be accepted by the market themselves so
that's I wish all the success I think
the chances are slim but it's good to
tempt to make attempt i would say i
would call this so it's verse trying to
this because it's better always to
anticipate the trouble because we know
the trouble will come monday nobody
knows exactly when where these bikes
bikes bikes and then we would say well
commodity trading should be change its
better at least intellectually to
address this issue and that i think is a
ambition of french presidency on energy
sectors between all the regulation EU
and united states i would say they are
not too much similarities I think I'm
perhaps now I have not followed this
dossier
u.s. is built differently in this
respect so it's for me it's difficult to
also also legislative process is
difficult is different so we went from
the basic logic of the you and still if
I would say what we have addressed its
basic electricity it was not so much or
transport sectors that we have addressed
it's indirectly covered by the
technology and indirectly covered by
well a bit of co2 emissions etc so I
would say the regulatory frameworks are
different at this stage and there is
perhaps some similarities but not too
many but it's for scholars really to
look upon it in the detail whereas vite
is so different because I believe that
our experience is a bit of universal in
this respect would it be good to some of
the principles to use more broadly
definitely it would be helpful emission
trading scheme I think well it's their
intellectual you can discuss perhaps
global carbon tax would be better but
it's gone I would say it's gonna be via
will be not able to come to it so the
first driver actually decides the pace
so if only heats is wrong I would just
make example we haven't likely of rather
stay debate should we devalue eight the
currency or not but unfortunately for us
Estonians where they take ins decision
before us because they will join euro so
we are so small so close to it we have
known as a policy option if even would
like to do this we just throw destroy
ourselves and our neighbors so I think
with the emission trading scheme being
holding and used at least in one region
these experiences I think it would be
clever to use it globally because that
is a reasonably good driver of
investment the difficulty today they
have been too much flotation because
market was rather small and the other
part of was difficulty was well it's
related to financial crisis so the price
was rather low to really to stimulate
huge impact on investment but in ideal
case I would definitely prefer market
based in mechanism not mechanisms
related with regulation admitted
regulation that we have introduced quite
a lot but we should not underestimate
them for example a united united kingdom
has a rather decent arm well market they
also come decent carbon market and not
investments in energy sector renewable
energy sector why it is so because in
energy is also other issues related if
the grid operator is independent then
it's a bit better but if the grid
operator is not independent then you
basically will never have a chance for
renewable energy even with best
efficient programs second it is all the
permits so I for example I learned in
one of the cities in Europe that you
have windmills you need to make a study
how it will affect make environment but
if you'd only make a new one mill mill
bill then the next investor will need
again to make the study because this one
min mill perhaps influenced the whole
thing so you come huge and mr. burden
that's why I would say for the start
still these strong regular measures are
very very helpful because in energy
sector has a lot of specificity it's not
very classical sector so i would say
administ if NASA measures are needed
just to to move forward but I am very
much supporting that experiences should
be universal drivers should be in aversa
and with due respect to the flotation of
oil prices I would say it has served us
reasonably well so perhaps in recent
times the fluctuations have been extreme
but it helped as a point of departure
right or wrong for everything we do in
energy so it was helpful it was helpful
and it is global so people complain
about it that it doesn't take some
elements but it is global and it's
called
so this would be the last one okay okay
now I think of either to be very brief
in answering because I saw the three
either Lance were very very if it's
possible very briefly so I do not belong
sir I I will make it right so my
question is how do you see the turn to
sustainable forms of energy under the
current economic environment and I will
give an example for example the current
Greek government won the elections with
a great strategic plan to transform
Greece as a green paradise in European
sound and out of suddenly they had to
pull back because maybe it was just too
expensive or it wasn't the time to do
that right now and a very short second
question what's Commission's position on
the proposal of President Sarkozy for a
topping tax this more relevant to your
current portfolios yeah for the first
issue well greased Anathem other
countries of the you have structural
funds and I think the best ways to use
is to use in energy sector Greece has a
lot of energy challenge and I think the
economic when you dress the crisis it's
a median budget consolidation but the
end of the day you need to slow the
sectors which you promote an energy is
arrived on this top in fact on financial
transaction work tax commission has not
very strong opposition I am very much in
favor of it provided that it is used for
development purposes because i sees a
need to really for how more for
developing countries to really to make
the change and so I in favor
thank you for the inspiring talk you
mentioned alternative energy and also as
one of the possible solutions to address
this but I'm wondering what do you see
the row of nuclear energy in the medium
term and in the long term as a possible
contributor to the solution well I am
taking his opinions a twist we went in
the nuclear we learn how to deal with
and nuclear is part of zionsville it's
part of the answer I know that people
are polarized but it's more political
perception because of well some
remembers Second World War and some also
have the member Chernobyl but it's
emotional perception of it I'm very
favorable in a way but saying says this
renewable energy is on by scale what you
could achieve you can achieve much more
as compared with nuclear so nuclear is
part of science for energy challenges
but it has a lot of also it's not easy
technologies a lot of people would think
so that's I but it's it's part of sounds
fun my question is related to US policy
and how this could translate possibly to
a smaller scale policy for state and
local policymakers here since we don't
have a federal anything going on really
right now in the federal space I guess
we you know our local policymakers need
to convince voters that this will create
jobs that this will increase economic
growth what recommendations do you have
for these policymakers to become a part
of the solution as well well if I see
that the well us well on political level
basically there is very much convergence
I saying cord concerns a need for energy
technology investment well what could I
say that some on this issue for local
policymakers you need to know financial
incentives so I don't see anything else
us are more pragmatical
citizens and in Europe Europe you can I
think also to make all convincing
speeches back up sees us local
municipalities you need to convince
through the incentives and then it works
then it works even in more skeptical
communities they would say well I have
incentive government wants me to do this
I would do this that's would be my
advice but it's so it's so far based on
the European experience and it's
difficult to say if it's correct and I
think now it's the last hello my name is
Danielle during this summer i went to
mexico and i worked with the Secretary
of Energy doing our research for
electricity for real communities a
Mexico is a country that that has 3.5
million people without electricity
Mexico has their the regulatory system
to allow the private sector to to invest
in generation and distribution of
electricity for rural communities
however I found that there are no
companies or enterprises of of the of
the private sector that are providing
these services one of my phones where
that there is lack of information of
work these people is located and a which
are there economics activities and I
think that this is a barrier for the
private sector to to invest I would like
to know if if you know that if you know
that this happens all around the world
and if there is a potential to invest
like a in in in knowing more about these
rural communities where they are located
and which other economic activities well
as i know this issue but now i will come
bit like marxist i would say because
it's sub pop need and if the companies
are not going there and not financed is
not responded to initiatives i would
create a state old company for providing
rural communities with electricity it's
not very market-friendly you would say
but because we I don't
anybody else it provides a service
because for complexity and lack of
interest then you create a company and
if its profitable you privatize it later
on so I would go this way but but there
is no one has answered the questions you
asked so as for my knowledge it's still
political discussions at how we provide
well a twisty for more developed regions
in the you it's not exactly the case
basically everybody's covered with
electricity for us it's a bit different
type of dilemma because we don't face
the situations that people don't have
electricity so basically well i would
say hundred percent are supplied with
electricity we try to make changes
portfolio of generation but i would say
provider if there is no companies that
are interested in our for governments of
world to participate in engine create a
state-owned company and i think that's
the way Cabrales some words go build and
well it's a lot of countries have had
very positive experience for particular
tasks you create a company and it's
gross well that would be my advice on
this issue thank you very much chemistry
you may have witness that there is a
very big interest for this for this
method the next lecture will be the vice
chairman of Khan Yunis and we'll have a
test drive of an electric car so you
like plugins we that will be the topic
of the of the next lecture and thank you
very much for coming here